ziemlich harte kerle die haudegen selber
wochen ziemlich weichen kern sie weinen
nämlich bei ihren eigenen liedern wann
und warum das jetzt im talk und danach
der vater wir diese cd und dvd live in
der passionskirche mit ihren autogrammen
gewinnen könnt es gibt also keinen
besseren grund für bis dann bleib an
rief die lage entspannt also wir sind
zusammen so leichter bettschwere jetzt
momentan aber ist alle nehmen woher
kommt die bettler die bettschwere kommt
daher weil gerade so herrliche erste
name indisch nicht meine ist jetzt
natürlich zu tieren gravierender
unterschied ja das ist wirklich zu sehen
du bist halt eher so der gleiche typ
etwas schwarzes jahr und wir sind halt
die etwas korpulentere jungs naja aber
auch kaffee gaal nicht nur kräftige in
der bauchmuskulatur hören auf ihr katja
kräftig okay mein opa sagt jud vollkorn
und gute butter bringt den vater auf der
mutter besser verstanden
dem habe ich nichts hinzuzufügen das ist
alle genetik wie macht man den zeitgeist
am schlafittchen nimmt der müssen
durchschüttelt und gleichzeitig also mit
der rechten den zeitgeist treffen auch
ein bisschen halt mit der linken den
nagel auf den kopf treffen der gruppe so
kann man es schaffen dass man von hier
auf gleich und jetzt sozusagen in die
top ten charts kommt okay wenn man
ehrliche musik macht ehrliche musik aus
leidenschaft macht dort wieder zur sense
zurück zu gehen und zu sagen was will
ich eigentlich mit der musik welchen
sinn hat diese musik die ich mache
damit kannst du sozusagen wieder punkten
insofern dass du bestes beispiel deine
eigenen schwächen auch mal wieder zeigst
andere menschen sich in den schwächen
wiederfinden im hip hop zum beispiel
gerne mal als beispiel wo wir herkommen
da ist das verpönt verpönt eine schwäche
zusammen gottes willen ich muss jeden
tag an der straßenecke stehen muss den
hafen
gangster mir da gehalten der gehört zum
guten ton
wir haben auch schwächen zugegeben zur
webseiten aber du weißt was ich meine
heutzutage ist es halt dann so dass das
ich denke dass der trend dahin geht zu
sagen komm zeig doch einfach das nun
einfacher mensch bist gewollt das wort
fans eigentlich eigentlich im unten dem
wald für uns unsere augen wieder wie
eine abwertung klingt weil es ging
erlebte er mit uns zusammen unsere musik
sozusagen nach hause zu sein spricht ja
dafür zu sein dass aufrichtiger mensch
man geht grabes leben tisch hauen
man hat liebe in sich man weiß einfach
wie das leben spielt sei normal beginnen
und die haudegen kopf uns zu und sagt
binding identifiziere mich so mit eurer
musik kann mit ruhigem gewissen sagen
bin haudegen oder eben die damenwelt
sagt ich bin nach haudegen durch und
durch und es war uns nicht bewusst und
so was passiert einfach und die gruppe
das beste beispiel dafür dass man den
zeitgeist am schlafittchen hatte
manchmal ja also wir haben also besser
beispiel wir haben einen tsonga ist
alles gute von dieser welt und trauern
wir praktisch mit dem publikum zusammen
weil jeder einzelne seinen eigenen
schmerz für einen menschen empfindet den
irgendwann mal gehen lassen musste weil
er halt gestorben ist und wir sehen den
für uns und die fans singen mit uns
zusammen und
ja da rollen noch mal drehen natürlich
die wahre stärke ist schwäche zeigen in
der heutigen zeit in der zeit wo sich
immer mehr menschen ein igeln und immer
mehr menschen in der anonymität leben
ist schwäche zeigen die größte stärke
die man besitzen kann und ich glaube
dies spiegelt sich in unserer musik auch
wieder und das sehen wir auch mal wenn
du künstler bist nur für bühne stehst
und einen song performance denn du
wirklich ernst meinst ist das größte für
werth ihren mensch schenken kann dass
dieser mensch weint weil er etwas mit
deiner musik verbindet es sagen dann
immer mehr mädels oder jungs oder kerl
wie ein baum die drehen sich dann weg
weil sie nicht zeigen wollen dass sollen
aber wir sprechen die auf den konzerten
an und sagen ey kanzlerin und ich
vollkommen in ordnung des vereins und
weil es die ehrliche emotionen ist über
jeden kannst tränen kannst du nicht
verbergen
die kommen einfach und dann verbindest
du damit wird und wie soll ich sagen es
ist die größte auszeichnung logik von
künstler wenn ein mensch nach einem
performten titel brennt und wenn er live
in der passionskirche mit den haudegen
gewinnen wollt dann schreibt unter dem
putz mit diesem video auf facebook warum
gerade ihr diese cd und dvd verdient
habt also guckt auf facebook.com / pixum
nachdem post mit diesem video
und dann schreibt drunter und ansonsten
wenn euch dieser tor gefallen hat kann
ich euch auch den mit nazar empfehlen
der erklärt was crowe wichtiges für den
deutschen hiphop getan hat und sehr
lustig auch der talk mit kopfhörer die
begründet warum man rtl mit eiern
bewerfen sollte also wenn er dafür
gründe sucht bykow raffinerie bis dann
bleibt dran